This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown.
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Hello, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the very unprofessional podcast, whereby I, your unqualified guide, talk through some of the big life transitions in our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Welcome back, everyone. Today we have some very special guests if you'd like to introduce you as the hills.
I'm Maddie. And? My name is Meg. Oh, good job. You know, for as much as you guys were talking before this, I didn't think it was going to be a struggle to say your own name. No, Maddie was going first. I made the eye contact.
Really? I thought the eye contact was you were going to go first. I thought it was you anyway. A miscommunication, guys. Which is what we need to talk about. Good segue, Meg. She's a natural. I know. So this was kind of a spontaneous episode.
Basically, the glorious Maddie, she's back from Queensland. Darwin. Excuse me. I'm sorry. Well, she's back from Darwin, but she had to travel through Queensland. Sunshine State. I did. The Sunshine State.
Yeah. To get to Canberra. And the other day, she got back and she messaged me these really cool questions. And it's not really like a typical episode, but I thought we'd answer some of them. Maybe we should talk about what these questions are. And also, I'm just an add-on, by the way. Thanks for inviting me. No, you're here to contribute a unique perspective of a 20-something-year-old.
No, she just my housemate, so we thought, oh, we should. Mine as well include her. Okay, continue. No, we value your insights. Yeah, no, I found these questions on TikTok. Oh, is that not on. There was this guy talking about, like, this college in Oxford. It's just a residential college, but in order to get in, it's a very rigorous selection process,
and they make you sit four, three-hour exams. It's 12 hours in total. Yeah, in total. It used to be five. And then you have to have an interview where there's like 50 people interviewing you, and they admit one to two people every year. It's really, really selective. That's just silly.
And all of this information is from TikTok. Why is it that selective? Because what do you get out of it? Oh, because you get funding to do research on whatever you want for seven years. At Oxford. At Oxford. Yeah. No, at a different meeting.
At Cambridge. At Cambridge. You're emphasising, yes, yes. It's the best university out there nearly. Uh-huh. And then you're just living with other people doing their seven years of research. But if only two. you get admitted what about all those other people?
Where did they come from? From previous years? So the college must only have like 20 people in there. Because you're there for seven years that you really... It takes a long time to filter people out. That's only 14 people. So that's a pretty small college.
It's a very small. Wait, is that how the maths would work? Isn't it like? Seven years? Maybe when they set it up, they were like, you know what, we'll be generous. We'll let like 100 people in. And then since then,
they've only been adding like one or two people and it takes a long time to filter people out because they get seven years. Anyway, the point is seven years of funding. Maybe they, no, I think what happens is they have the people who are like all the rich kids who have to pay and then this is a scholarship for the ones who like can't pay but probably rich kids still get it.
Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's fair. I mean, I definitely could have looked at this college like beyond the TikTok that I watched. No, who cares? And, well, you know, I just want a fact check and not be a culprit of spreading misinformation.
Good. So basically on this exam, they ask a bunch of these, like, very abstract, intellectual questions. Yeah, I think they're questions that really kind of underpin the world. Humanity. Yeah. Good. Chinks. Good on you.
We're watching Hummedallies. And they're very, like, interrelated. Like, it's different fields. And we thought we would answer some of the psychology questions and see whether Meg, Maddie, and Gemma would get. into Oxford College. Oh, I really think that we would. I think we would as well. Well, we'll have to see, but maybe we should, like,
probably, I should probably just give you guys more of an introduction. Tell everyone how we met. Oh, yeah. Get them familiar before we deep dive. So, Meg, how did we meet? Well, we went to BNG together, but we weren't friends. Yeah, and I think we both thought we hated each other. I remember you told me, like, I thought you hated me.
And I was like, oh, my God, I thought, Jimmy, you hated me. No, I was so intimidated by you. Oh, intimidated. That's probably a better word. Yeah, I was so intimidated by you. Like this is how so many strong friendships died. I thought you hated me at this story. And then last year we, who were?
I didn't even know how. Was it? I don't know. Was it Tenaia or Jasmine maybe? We basically just hung out once. It was here. I remember and I was like, we had a good conversation in this lounge room of the street
that must not be named. And their house and it's beautiful. Is that where it was? And then we just started hanging out now. I sent you a message saying I really enjoyed that conversation. Oh, I remember. this okay we can't actually talk about why what we were doing it up because i really want to know what it is no i know exactly what it was i drove you guys to mac oh that that's oh yeah and then can i tell
the funny story okay so i was hadn't had anything to drink so i drove them to macas it was me and two others and jasmine and erin someone's birthday it was someone's birthday wasn't it yeah it was jasmine's birthday yeah oh that makes sense it was a year ago basically yeah and um so i drove them up to, we got McDonald's and then I drove them up to Mount Ainsie. And there were these two people having sex in a car. And I was driving and Jasmine, I hate to call her out. It wasn't just Jasmine. Where was all of us? All of you guys just really wanted to see them having sex.
We were drive, we were doing this loop like three or four times. It was foggy. The windows were foggy. Windows were foggy, but like I just felt so bad because we kept driving past their car and every time we'd drive past their car, Jasmine or one of you would be like, slow down. Yeah, we throw it down so much. I was at a standstill and you guys were just staring at this car, but that's how we met. Oh, you're going to go back and find the first message.
Well, how about while you do that? Maddie, how did we meet? I think we had chaps at B&G. Yeah. But I think we both did a lot of like extracurricular shit that like overlapped. Bossy? Bossy, yeah. What else?
And you're a very chatty, easy to talk to person. So, yeah, I think you're really easy to start off a friendship with. That's so nice. You're a good podcaster too. Oh, guys, stop it. I found the message. Actually, it wasn't that overwhelming. Like, it wasn't very, like, but I think that's what stemmed our friendship.
Oh, hope the foot down went okay. I don't know what that meant. I was about my ex-housemate. Oh. This satanic being who shall not be named. I can't. Oh, yeah. I can't even, yeah.
Anyway, that's. And what did you say? I said thank you. Had a fun evening with you. Thanks for driving also. And then, yes. This is a really detailed history. We must know.
We don't need to cut it out. If people are listening to this, they want to hear us. But also, Meg and I live together. We do. We do. Yeah. Oh, she's moving your neck closer to me. She's looking it over me.
Should I leave? Or no. Well, funny, I was doing that Centrelink thing last night And it was like, any of your housemates, couples? Like, are you a couple with any of them? And there was like three questions, like, meeting the same thing, but they were like, just wanted to check. Wait, is the census?
CenterLink. Oh, Centrelink. Yeah, and have you participated in activities that you would call yourself a couple? So have you had sex with your housemates? Do you live with them in the same room? Do you share expenses? There was so many questions. about, but we're not a couple, I don't think.
Dude, if that's... No, not since I last check, but I'm definitely open to having a conversation if, you know. If things change. I actually think if that's a definition of a couple, me and Ariana would count as a couple. In sentencing it is. Yeah, me and Ariana would literally count as a couple
because we share expenses, like, sometimes we sleep in the same bed, like, have cuddles, like... Oh. Yeah, they don't have anything, like, with the word, like, sexual in it, so... Maybe, but... Both of us are asexual in their eyes. Okay, anyhow, let's move on. How long are these podcast episodes meant to be?
To be honest, like, I... We've got to just keep going. Well, we can stop it if you guys want. But to be honest, like, I just kind of just talk. And here's the thing, like, it's kind of my podcast. I'm kind of like, if you want to listen to this, you're happy to welcome to listen to this. But it's also more like a diary entry for me where I'm like, the people I bring on are people that are really important in my life at the moment. obviously guys are important to me.
Stop. So it's like, as much as people might get entertainment out of this, they can skip past this if they want. Yeah, it's sort of like a journal thing. Yeah, it's more for me. Like, I know my audience is not massive. Like, it's just more that I get to have these great discussions. It's building.
It's gradually increasing. But yeah, thanks for introducing yourself, guys. So let's answer some of these questions that Maddie found through her TikTok. some of the Oxford College entrance questions. I feel like this is just going to be more of a discussion because I feel like it's really interesting to offer different perspectives and like deep dive into it. Yeah, definitely.
And I think that question is whether it's not really right or wrong. No. Yeah. So please think about it as well. Yeah. Let us know. Send us a message on Instagram if you're woefully offended by anything we've said. Or if you just have an addition.
If you have an addition, if you agree with us. But if you disagree, we don't want to hear it. Yeah. Yeah. Just, I'm just going to block you. Spam. Yeah. Okay, Meg has the first question.
Okay. It is. Is the internet changing the ways in which we think? Good question. That's a very broad question. I think it's obvious it is, but... But then I think it depends, like, how you narrow it down. Because, like, if you think about internet as an isolated concept,
it's also expanded the way we think about things as well. Yeah. globalised like our world but are we are we including like big data and algorithms into this question or are we talking more about like the immense accessibility of information that the internet is facilitated or there's that one example have you watched the social dilemma yeah like you know how like there's like if you are like far left or far right and then you like they if you I don't know how it is if you vote or if you just follow like a lot of like a lot of like there's like if you are like like like like far right politicians, then you get like into this spiral, this like negative
empty back. If you follow like centre right and then it takes you on a rabbit hole to an event for you end up extreme right. And you can never see other views. You can never see other views. So it's like. So it does kind of change the way we think because it's like now I feel like previously opinions were more up for discussion.
Whereas if you spent a lot of time on the internet, especially as we all did last year when we're all like inside our homes, it's actually harder to get a diverse opinion on things and especially like you can kind of cherry pick the information that you want rather than, and also it's so accessible to find evidence for your own opinion whereas previously you had to go read a textbook, you have to go to the library but that's like... Yeah, you were kind of forced to read more diverse sources of information.
Because like I feel like with the internet and like what do you call technology coming on I know like the generations of like 10 year olds now can't think for themselves because they've got phones to search up on Google like when we were 10 we fucking had oh you know you can swear you can swear yeah um we had to go out and like you know make up ideas for ourselves yeah literally we have to think for ourselves and that's actually like I always think about this I'm like are we going to lose our like process of this is a bit I know what I mean like we can just search on Google like get our phone literally in our pocket for like 10 seconds yeah also it reduces how we entertain like our cognitive thinking is going to be like
fuck actually this can all be so summarized in the um you know the boberdam Netflix special yes no I watched it oh is that that's cute no I watched it but I was high so I didn't know I didn't know anything and everything all of the time yes that is oh the one that with the fucking the
the skinny song no the song oh yeah that's the song I showed you yes and I watched it but I was like oh good good looking at it as I was like but I think that's a really good point also make kind of off like what you were saying because there's more accessibility of information as well it means that all these people who previously wouldn't have gone and read textbooks wouldn't have gone and read gone and borrowed books from the library wouldn't have gone to like saloons or like gone into lectures or gone to university now actually have access to information so it changes the way that we think in that
like more people are actually accessing information who previously wouldn't have. That's a good point. But then the downside of that is that the information that they're accessing can sometimes actually lead to reduce cognition because yeah, it's misinformation. That's a completely other point.
Yeah. Oh, Maddie's got a quote. She ran up stairs. Did you hear her? Elephant feet. She's got elephant feet. She was like, go-going. She just sprinted.
Yeah, we didn't get any. I do get criticized by elephant feet around here. All the time. Yes. No, it just reminded me of this book that I'm reading at the moment. It's by Thomas Friedman. Great. Thomas Friedman.
No, no, he's American. Milton, it's a very Jewish name. Oh, yeah, it is, Friedman. I actually know Milton Friedman. I know a guy who lives in Israel. Sexy. But anyway, he kind of talks about the whole concept of the book is that technology is accelerating at a quicker pace than our kind of social ability and the ability of our institutions to address.
adapt to those changes. And the section I was reading just this afternoon, so this is super like, yeah, weird and coincidental, is about social media and the internet and he points out, no, no, no, I'm not going to read, yeah, I'm going to read the entire book.
Sit down, ladies and gentlemen, this is the beginning of my book review. Okay, what's the summary? Okay, some... Meg! Sorry, positive. But with the internet, we don't know
had a deal with rumors, rumors that confirm people's biases are now believed and spread among millions of people. Second, we create our own echo chambers, which we've kind of touched on. Third, online discussions quickly descend into angry mobs. Four, it became really hard to change our opinions because what you post online, you're somewhat wedded to. Yeah, and on a bit of a tangent, like with celebrities and asserting their political views. I feel like there's a bit of a discussion about this and people like, oh, they should stand out for this issue and that not whatnot. But I actually think it's really, really hard to maintain your political integrity
once you stand up for one thing. That's actually... Because you can't change your mind. And, yeah, the internet preserves those thoughts. We actually, humans hate change, though. Like naturally, because change is hard. As in like we all like I think all three of us are very progressive. But it requires new adapters.
Yeah, like change is good and we need it. But also like that actually like the internet kind of like makes us be more stagnant in a way because we like can't change what we think and change is always. I would actually disagree with you because I find that the algorithm just in like my personal growth has actually really adapted to the way that my life has changed. Like previously like when I was in a relationship I get a lot of like I'm just going to use the example of Instagram Reels. like i just because it's on the top of my mind like instagram so the instagram algorithm almost i find
adapts to what my interests are in that it kind of leads into that thing where i get a bit of an epistopic echo chamber because i just put this data in and it just gives it straight back to you think that your echo chamber is is better or more justified because because it's uh but it's not it's like it's like i don't okay so that's interesting so i think that the tictox and the and the Reels that I get a like very spiritual very new age very like that's what you're feeling at the moment yeah very fitness orientated very like I said spirituality but I don't have much political content but it means that if that's the main platform that I consume my news from or my media from obviously I do like read the news and do other things but like it's the main and online platform
I use the only information I'm getting from it is just stuff that like reinforces all the things I already already yeah yeah and I'm I already believe. But where did you get, did you, when that first come up, did you search up, was it you like, I really want to get into like,
no, it's like, so you just one of them would come up, you like it. And then, you know, in a couple weeks, two of them come up.
You like both of those. So it, like, adapts to the way that your mindships, which I find good because it's like, you have to search up in the first place. You know what I mean?
Like, if you've got, so I've come back to camera and it's like a full new thing. And I have to search up like, you know, not what TikTok is, but you know,
like those kind of randomness trans-in-adena. Any idea? You're re-entering society. I'm re-entering the progressive society. Yeah, from far from like rural Victoria. No, I think that it's the thing where it's like you interact with enough posts and like obviously occasionally you're going to like run across one that is like more, it's fine, we're pouring some wine.
You're going to run across one that's more like and you're like, oh that's interesting and then so it builds to you. So it's like both a blessing and a person that the person I want to become is reinforced by the media I'm consuming. But I also see that if I was getting all of my media or my news content from my phone, from my, from Instagram, from Facebook, how quickly it would be just to like slip into one category of thinking. Yeah. And I think it's so insidious that you don't. It's very hard to have the level of self-awareness required to. That's a very good point because the internet can really. Also, don't you think it's interesting in our conversation about the internet, how immediately this conversation became about social media?
because we associate so many of the problems that the internet has produced with social media. But what about the internet more broadly if we look outside of like the social media discussion? Yeah. I think also it's changed the way that we can receive answers. I don't know, it's funny because then I'm immediately going back to social media. Like it's changed the way that we received gratification. So previously if we had a question, if we were seeking knowledge, if we were seeking stimulation, it would take a bit more. but now we pick up our phones, we go on the internet.
It actually makes that cognitive process, like you were saying, make a lot easier, a lot quicker. I also want to say it because I was just thinking with social, like, not just social, the internet or any, like, news or evidence thing on Google or whatever. Like, I think it really favours people who are more self-aware what you were saying, Maddie, and, like, intellectual. Like, if, I know so many people who have different, like, range of skills
and Anna's like, you know, university-educated and stuff, and they, like, they get sucked in really bad. And, like, scammed. Like, that's a bad case in order. You know, like, it really, the internet really, like, I don't know, I just find it's really like, what's the word? Disit, not just, like, it, I don't know what the word is. It kind of, like, people who can get sucked in by, who, depending on who you are, you know,
like, it favours people who are more, like, educated. One of the other question. on this list was, is do internet users have equal equality? Or internet users equal. They're not, no way. And I think, yeah, what you're saying is kind of delving into that. They're not. Also, it depends on what you use the internet for because I feel like it almost replicates
a class structure that exists in real life. Like, if you use the internet for academic purposes, like we would be doing or for research purposes or for work purposes, you know, your experience with the internet, you would probably see it more as a tool. Whereas if you were someone who is getting scammed, if you were someone who perhaps the internet is showing you all the things that you can't be, or, you know, perhaps you're growing up in a rural community or in a poorer community,
like the internet, yeah, it would be beneficial to you, but it might also... It's more just, like, could we just be like a, not entertainment, but, you know, like, you just go on there to... It's addictive. To prove because if you've got nothing else to do. Yeah, in real, you literally, there's nothing to do. So you just literally, what else is there to do? There's no, like, see, you know, life.
So you could say that it's changed the way that we think in that sense because people don't really have to sit with themselves and how they feel anymore. That's such a big thing. Do you ever find that where you're, like, in a bad mood and you're like, Instagram, Facebook? We need to think of our own thoughts. But we all, we can't help. I remember, like, talking to a boss of mine a few years ago, and, I was he was, like, quite a bit older. and he was talking about like breaking up with someone
and then he had to take a really long bus ride back to his place and it was like an hour and a half or two hours on public transport and he had forgotten his headphones. And he was saying, you know, in hindsight, I'm actually really glad that I didn't have my headphones. I guess listening to music on Spotify is not really... It's enabled by the internet. It's a distraction.
It's a distraction. Yeah. I do that all the time. Like how much do we actually, with the creation of the internet and I guess we could make the argument for radio and things like that but now that it's compact it follows you everywhere that we've got mobile phones
and the internet it's like a distraction yeah how often are you alone and has it changed the way we if we like kind of going back to the actual question like has it changed the way that we think like yeah has it made us less resourceful because you know we have Google Maps at our fingertips and obviously there's a lot of dialogue about how it's changed
our attention span It definitely has. Well, that's where I was kind of heading is, like, I was thinking, well, just then, it just came up to me. Like, you know, the reason, when I, like, get really anxious or, like, you overthink things, which is very common these days. Well, maybe that's because, anyway, we won't go there. But, like, is it because, like, if I use, like, the internet and, like, Spotify and music to, like, distract myself? But, like, you know, back in the day, back, you know, 40 years ago, how did people work with their overthinking thoughts?
Like, how do they work with their anxieties? I don't know. I just like, that's like, I just feel that thing. I find it really interesting with the anxiety thing because I think it's kind of ironic that the internet really created a lot of services that should inherently reduce anxiety but have actually exacerbated it. Well, it's like the self, what's the image, the body, you know, body image and things like that. Well, also just like the internet as a means for comparison with anything in your life.
It's like we do kind of keep shifting on to sort of. social media. Like, just the means of comparison. But I actually might make an argument that it actually has improved the way we think because it's increased the possibilities that people feel they have. Yeah, that's a good point. Because it's expanded your worldview. It's back to like the spiral of like, are you, if you're aware of that or if you go down
the case, like, oh, I don't, like, I see that skinny, you know, word of eyes. But anecdotally, like, imagine there's like someone in, you know, like, we've been using this rural example because I feel like that's a real benefit for people who aren't in, like, centers of knowledge of the internet is really useful for them. Imagine, you know, being able to see that, like, university is a possibility and not having to be connected with someone to the university, you know, there are scholarships. Like, it's changed the way we think in that, like, it has expanded our options, but also limited them or narrowed, like honed them in to perhaps specific thing when we think about political opinions, but it's also expanded how we think
and that we see that more things are available to us. But I think at the same time, it's a double-edged sword and that we definitely do realize there's greater possibilities and we're almost overwhelmed with choice but at the same time we realize our utter disposability oh because if you I was wondering when this is going to turn like really
existential I learned that word in French last week I can't say it existential you'll get there but I couldn't I had to search out what it was wait back to Maddie's existential point how disposable we are oh yes because I think that a lot of
a lot of labor can be really, really easily outsourced through software, through the internet now. Whereas previously, that would have been sourced locally. Yeah, but also it's like that's allowed industry to expand and allowed production to expand. Very, that's very capitalist. Yeah, yeah. But if we're thinking about, like, how it's changed the way you think, like I think if you were growing up pre-internet, you being kind of one of the best in your, field in your town, your city, your area, wherever you live, like that was really impressive.
现在很多劳动力都可以通过软件和互联网非常、非常轻易地外包出去。而在此之前，这些都是在本地寻找的。是的，但这同时也让行业得以扩张，让生产得以扩张。这非常资本主义。没错，没错。但如果我们思考，比方说，它如何改变你的思维方式，比如我认为如果你在互联网出现之前长大，你在你的城镇、城市、地区——无论你住在哪里——的同行或领域中名列前茅，那真的让人印象深刻。
Yeah. Just part of your identity. Impressive and, yeah, but with the internet now, you're so much more aware of, you know, the software developer on the other side of the world who is better than you. Yeah, like it's more international. Yeah. Yeah. I saw, oh, it's not really at all related.
对。这只是你身份的一部分。令人印象深刻，而且，是的，但有了互联网，你会更加清楚地意识到，你知道，世界另一端的那个软件开发人员比你更优秀。是的，它更国际化了。没错。是的。我看到，哦，其实这完全没有关系。
What is? It's like, you know when like countries interfere, this is a whole different. Yeah, no, please, no, talk about. There are so many facets to this question. You know when countries interfere, like, I don't want, like an example of like in the Middle East when like America interfered. You know, like things like that. It's like globalization in that sense is that I don't really know much about this topic, but, you know. Yeah, globalization.
什么关系？就像，你知道当国家之间进行干涉时，这完全是另一码事。是的，不，请，谈谈吧。这个问题有很多方面。你知道当国家干涉时，比如说，我不想，比如在中东，美国进行干涉的那种例子。你知道，诸如此类的事情。这就好比那种意义上的全球化，虽然我其实对这个话题不太了解，但你知道的。对，全球化。
Because there's a question on this exam that was like, is international development aid good? Oh, yeah. I like that kind of was like, because we're being globalised, that's able to happen, but also like... How does it, is it used for manipulation as well? Yeah. Political reasons rather than just humanitarian. Well, I feel like we're going in a rabbit circle. Should we do the next question?
因为这次考试里有一道题是这样的：国际发展援助是件好事吗？哦，对。我觉得那题有点像是，因为我们正处于全球化进程中，所以这种事才会发生，但也觉得……它是怎么运作的？它也被用来进行操控吗？是的。是为了政治原因，而不仅仅是出于人道主义。好吧，我觉得我们陷入了一个无休止的死胡同。我们要不要做下一道题？
Yeah, I think. Yeah. Okay. Which question do you have made? Wait, who asked that question? Do you want to ask a question, Maddie? Yeah. Oh, actually, I'm like, can I ask one?
对，我想是的。好的。你们出了哪道题？等等，是谁问的那个问题？Maddie，你想问个问题吗？好。哦，其实，我在想——我能问一个吗？
Yeah. This one's like a little bit missed. Okay, it's kind of a bit of a change. And it's very... The same thing. Yeah. Okay, who is the most overrated figure in your discipline? Oh, I think you're eager to talk about this.
可以。这个有点微调。好吧，这算是一个小小的转变。而且它非常……是一样的。好吧，在你的学科中，最被高估的人物是谁？哦，我觉得你很急着想谈这个。
The reason I ask is, because I- Yeah, I just want to, like, talk shit about the people in my, not like people I know, but, like, in psychology and philosophy, I think is so overrated. Like, okay, firstly, Adam Smith is, like, political economy, like... Okay, I'm going to say she's got it. The wealth of nations. Oh my God.
我问这个的原因是，因为我——是的，我只是想，就像痛骂我学科里的人一样，倒也不是我认识的人，而是心理学和哲学领域的人，我觉得真的被严重高估了。比如说，首先，亚当·斯密，就像政治经济学一样……好吧，我要说她懂。国富论。天哪。
You know, there is more to political thinking than some white guy who fucking... He's Scottish. He's Scottish. He was white. He was from Glasgow. He was from Calioli or something like that. He's old. Well, no, he's dead.
你知道的，政治思想不仅仅关乎某个白人混蛋……他是苏格兰人。他是苏格兰人。他是白人。他来自格拉斯哥。他来自卡利奥利还是什么地方。他很老了。好吧，不，他已经死了。
He's not still alive. 16th century. Yeah, like, I just think that, like, Adam Smith is so overrated, rational thought, so overrated. The emphasis on self-interest, so overrated. And every single course I always learn about it. And I'm just like, really, can we retire the idea that this one person is like the forefather of every single economic and political thought that we've ever held? He's not curzing his hair as well. Oh, lame.
他现在已经不在了。16th 世纪。是的，我只是觉得，亚当·斯密被严重高估了，理性思考也被严重高估了。对自私自利的强调，也被严重高估了。而且在每一门课上我总是能学到这些。我当时就想，真的，我们能让这个观点退休吗：就是认为这个人是我们所拥有的每一个经济和政治思想的鼻祖？他的头发也没卷好。哦，太逊了。
He's like, like, I just, I just feel like we need to have more of a diversity of thinkers. The other one who I really, sorry, I'm just like kind of granting. Can I just say a quote from him, I think. Yeah. All money is a matter of belief. Why is it about money? Am I just thinking? He's an economist.
他就像是，我只是，我只是觉得我们需要更多元化的思想家。另外一个我真的——抱歉，我有点在发牢骚。我能引述他的一句话吗，我觉得。是的。所有的金钱都关乎信仰。为什么这跟钱有关？我是不是在瞎想？他是个经济学家。
Fuck money. Honestly. What? Or Matt Yeah, so it makes sense Anyway, what's his second? Well, he has this huge emphasis on self-interest Which I do think is rational
去他的钱。说真的。什么？或者说 Matt 是的，所以这说得通。不管怎样，他的第二点是？好吧，他极度强调自私自利。我觉得这倒算理性。
Like to believe But just annoys me I'm sure Maddie you find this as well With like PPE Yeah, no, he's definitely Hammered on Hammered A lot
就信仰而言。但就是很烦人。我相信 Maddie 你也会有同感，对于 PPE 课程。是的，不，他绝对被狠狠地批判了。被反复提及。
Yeah The second one is like There are all these Psychologists Who I just like, like John Watson And B.F Skinner An example
对。第二点是，有所有这些心理学家，我真的很讨厌，比如约翰·华生（John Watson）和 B.F. 斯金纳（B.F. Skinner），这就是个例子。
Yeah, you know him right? No, I know him from Shellaw in Sherlock. How do you know him from Sherlock Holmes? John Watson. Who's that? He's like Sherlock's comrades. Oh, I have not watched Sherlock Holmes. 221B, they live together.
对，你知道他，对吧？不，我知道他是因为《神探夏洛克》里的雪洛克。你怎么会从《神探夏洛克》里知道他？约翰·华生。那是谁？他是夏洛克的同伴。哦，我没看过《神探夏洛克》。221B，他们住在一起。
Oh, that's cute. Yeah, anyway. Is Arthur Conan Doyle an overrated figure in literature? Is that one of the questions? No. No. No. He's the author of Sherlock.
哦，那挺可爱的。对，无论如何。亚瑟·柯南·道尔（Arthur Conan Doyle）是文学界被高估的人物吗？那是其中的一个问题吗？不是。不是。不是。他是夏洛克的作者。
Oh, okay. I'm learning so much. But yeah, there's also like this huge emphasis on like behaviorist, psychologists in the field of psychology and it really shits me because I'm like every course you learn about it it's like yes they understood how like behavior and learning occurred but like can we maybe what's an example okay so um bf skinner did like these boxes with rats in them and he learned that like i haven't learned that yet anymore condition uncondition stimulus it's great but it just gets like overplayed and it just feel like there are so many more creative ideas that have come out in
哦，好吧。我学到了很多。但话又说回来，在心理学领域，对行为主义心理学家也存在这种极大的强调，这真的很让我火大，因为我觉得你上的每一门课都会学到这些，就像是“是的，他们理解了行为和学习是如何发生的”，但是，我们能不能——举个例子？好吧，嗯，B.F.斯金纳用装有老鼠的箱子做了实验，他发现——我还没学到这个呢，条件反射、非条件反射，这挺棒的，但它就是被过度渲染了，而且我觉得在过去的100年或50年里，出现了那么多更有创意的想法，
the last like 100 years or 50 years that are actually being. provide a much better explanation than these experiments and it's like all I also just I think it's that general issue where I'm just like getting very frustrated that in a lot of my university courses they only teach about white male researchers. Well isn't like this is okay this is another thought for my brother but like yeah university is actually quite right wing like do you think so? Yes like the actual this is what he's I don't know I've I've thought about it a bit but like like the actual like it's a it's a huge structure of course it's right wing you know what i mean like the actual it's a what do you mean by right wing though like i think like i think like that i don't know i'm
这些想法实际上正在提供比这些实验好得多的解释。而且我觉得这也是那个普遍问题的一部分，让我感到非常沮丧的是，在我大学的很多课程中，他们只教白人男性研究人员。好吧，这难道不是——好吧，这是我弟弟的另一个想法，但是，是的，大学其实相当右翼，你觉得呢？是的，就像实际的——这就是他的观点，我不知道——我思考过一会儿，但是，就像实际的——这是一个巨大的结构，当然它是右翼的，你知道我的意思吗？就像实际的——它是一个，你说的右翼是什么意思？我觉得，像，我不知道，我
this is like just random brain thoughts but like the the not the teaching because i'm doing a virus science that obviously is the right wing but like um the actual like teaching style i don't know i'll have to do some more research it's a conservative teaching style yeah it's like yeah and like we're learning about yeah we're literally It's very repetitive and like it's structured. It's so structured. And it's all based on like ideas of like 50, 70, even hundreds of years ago that haven't been corrected,
这只是随性的脑洞，但是，不是教学本身，因为我学的是病毒科学，那当然不是右翼的，但是，嗯，实际的教学风格，我不知道，我还得再做点研究，这是一种保守的教学风格，对，就像，是的，而且我们在学习，是的，我们简直——这非常重复，而且很有结构。太有结构了。而且它们全都基于诸如50年、70年甚至几百年前的想法，这些想法从来没有被纠正过，
haven't been changed, even when they've been proven to be incorrect, even when better explanations are offered. And a lot of these people are very like, it's very conservative. They're all very traditional things. I do think the teaching is quite conservative in that I don't think they've adapted to the needs of society in the kind of job market that we're entering because I think that
从来没有被改变过，哪怕它们已经被证明是不正确的，哪怕已经有更好的解释被提出。而且这些人中的许多都非常——这非常保守。全都是非常传统的东西。我确实觉得教学相当保守，因为我觉得他们没有适应社会的需要以及我们正在进入的就业市场，因为我认为
universities are still somewhat living in the past where people were qualified with a certain skill and they used that skill in their career which really carried them through a lifetime but we're going to have a lot of different careers and in order to stay up to date and be kind of climb the ranks in whichever workforce you're in
大学在某种程度上仍然生活在过去，那时人们凭借某项特定技能获得资格，并在职业生涯中使用这项技能，这确实让他们受用终身。但我们将经历许多不同的职业，为了保持最新状态并在你所在的任何职场中晋升，
it does require lifelong learning and I don't think that universities have adapted to that and I think they're conservative in that sense. But to go back to the original question. Thank you for me. I always bring us back. Sorry. I was like you.
这确实需要终身学习，而我认为大学并没有适应这一点，从这个意义上说，它们是保守的。不过，回到最初的问题。谢谢你提醒我。我总是能把话题拉回来。抱歉。我就像你一样。
I was like, yes. Of who is an overrated person in your discipline. Like, and I think you all agree with me on this Gemma because we both do PPE. Economics is really, really outdated. Oh my God, yeah. And so they still, it's like my mom was showing me some of her stuff.
我当时想，对。关于谁是你学科里被高估的人。而且我觉得你们在这点上都同意我，Gemma，因为我们都学的是 PPE。经济学真的、真的过时了。哦，天哪，是的。所以他们仍然，就好像我妈妈在向我展示她的一些东西。
It's like rational man, rational economic man. self-interest that's that's it it's very it's very exclusionary find a demand I know that oh god no you're absolutely right and they teach these same models thinking that they've adapted it's like these models were created like 50 years ago I really they can expect a really outdated concept that stands out to me so much in economics is that when it comes to environment there was the kind of traditional response to that was like oh well the free market when when a resource is overused and over consumed, the free market will naturally like redirect us to
就像理性人，理性经济人。自私自利，就是这样，就是这样。这非常具有排他性。供求关系。我知道那个，哦天哪，不，你绝对是对的，他们教授这些相同的模型，还以为自己已经做出了调整。就像这些模型是50年前创建的一样。我真的——在经济学中，有一个非常突出的过时概念让我印象深刻，那就是当谈到环境时，传统的应对方式是：“哦，好吧，自由市场——当资源被过度使用和过度消费时，自由市场会自然而然地引导我们转向
other sources of production. It doesn't understand the idea of like exhaustion of a source. Yeah, okay. And you're just kind of sitting there like, well, yes, our coal industry. Yeah, it's like, oh, yeah, interesting. Or the other idea, it's like, oh yeah, if we lose jobs in one place, they'll be created elsewhere. So everything always reaches an equilibrium again. But then you would use that argument in favour of free trade.
其他生产来源。”它根本不懂资源枯竭的概念。是的，好吧。而你只会坐在那里想，好吧，是的，我们的煤炭产业。是的，这就好比，“哦，是的，真有趣。”或者另一种观点是：“哦，是的，如果我们在一个地方失去了工作，它们会在其他地方被创造出来。”所以一切总是会再次达到平衡。但随后你就会用这个论点来支持自由贸易。
Yeah. Yeah. But wait, what do you mean about that? But then I feel like you're using it as a negative argument right now. Well, what I'm saying is that it's not true. Like, especially in isolated industries or in an isolated community like Australia, where they're, like, it suggests that when people lose jobs in one area, new jobs are always created elsewhere. So say we shut down coal plantation. That's like their skill set.
对。对。但等等，你这话是什么意思？但我觉得你现在正把它当成一个反面论点在使用。嗯，我想说的是，这是不真实的。特别是对于孤立的行业，或者像澳大利亚这样孤立的社会，它们——这就暗示了当人们在一个领域失去工作时，新的工作总会在其他地方被创造出来。所以，假设我们关闭了煤矿。那是他们的技能组合。
That's what you were saying about their skill set. you know 40, 50 year old skills, they only have like a certain suit. They can't change it. It's incorrect. But we will be able to. Right wing economics is very much like the market fixes everything. Yes. Itself and those new industries, new avenues for disenfranchised people will be forced to open.
这就是你刚才说的关于他们的技能组合。你知道的，40、50岁的人的技能，他们只有某种特定的技能组合。他们无法改变。这是不对的。但我们能够做到。右翼经济学很大程度上认为市场能解决一切。是的。市场自身会运作，那些被剥夺权利的人的新产业、新途径将被迫开启。
And this is where you come to that big cleavage between left and right wing economics because when you get on the left wing it says, no, no, no, you need the government at that point to step in and like offer opportunities for upskilling or re-endings. or re-skilling so that people can have greater labour migration. And so I think a really overrated person in the field of economics would be Gregory Mankew. Gregory, like Gregory Mankew, yeah. I never heard of him before. He wrote, we didn't do macroeconomics in the same year, but he wrote the textbook that I
而这就是你遇到左翼和右翼经济学之间巨大分歧的地方，因为当你转向左翼时，它会说：“不，不，不，在这种情况下，你需要政府介入，提供提升技能或重新培训的机会，
used for Macro. Oh, yeah. I didn't use a textbook because I was just like this is all pretty simple. Yeah, no, that's fair. I received it for free, definitely not something that I would have paid money for. No. Also, I ask anyone who is also at the A&U, when you watch an economics lecture, watch every single lecture, you will never see a picture of a woman.
或者重新学习技能，以便人们能够拥有更大的劳动力流动性。”所以我觉得经济学领域一个真正被高估的人是格里高利·曼昆（Gregory Mankew）。格里高利，就像格里高利·曼昆一样，是的。我以前从未听说过他。他写了——我们不是在同一年学宏观经济学的，但他写的教材我
Dana. Dana's a lecturer, but I'm saying in the slides, you'll never see a picture of a woman. It's all, like, I don't know, I keep going back to this very feminist critique. It always goes back to gender. know how in economics, in economics, how when they thought of the concept of GDP, they did try to work out how to include
在宏观经济学中用过。哦，是的。我没用教材，因为我当时觉得这些都挺简单的。是的，不，这倒也合理。我是免费拿到它的，绝对不是我会花钱买的东西。不。另外，我问任何也在澳国立大学（ANU）上学的人，当你观看经济学讲座时，看每一场讲座，你永远不会看到一张女性的照片。
domestic labor into that equation, but they were like, no, it's too hard to measure. So they just didn't do it. We're too intricate. We're too distinct. And they were like, maybe we could ask, like, I don't know, someone who understands this, and they're like, no.
Dana。Dana是一位讲师，但我的意思是在幻灯片里，你永远不会看到一张女性的照片。全都是——我不知道，我又回到了这个非常女权主义的批判。这总是归结为性别。你知道在经济学中，在经济学中，当他们构思 GDP 的概念时，他们确实试图想方设法将
No. We won't ask a women. Their opinion would be too hysterical. It was too dramatic. They won't take their words. They can't even read. Yes. When they're not scientific.
家务劳动纳入该方程，但他们觉得：“不，这太难衡量了。”所以他们干脆没做。我们太复杂了。我们太独特了。然后他们想：“也许我们可以问问——我不知道，问问懂这个的人。”而他们的回答是：“不。
Yeah, exactly. They're just cleaners. The whole, all the academic. Cleaners. In the kitchen. Yeah. Sad. Speaking of which, we probably need to clean the kitchen at something.
不。我们不会去问女人。她们的意见会太歇斯底里了。太戏剧化了。我们不能采纳她们的话。她们甚至都不会识字。是的。她们根本不科学。
Oh, God. No, it's anti-feminist to clean the kitchen. In this room, we are surrounded by the matriarchy. We are. Oh, you really are. There's literally like nude prints in the world. It always comes down to gender. I'm wearing, like, naked woman earrings.
对，没错。她们只是清洁工。整个——所有的学术界。清洁工。在厨房里。是的。说到这儿，我们可能得抽空打扫一下厨房。
Key message in this. by podcast comes down to gender. I hope you're listening. And it's over our arc. Oh. That's really good. Yeah. Congratulations.
哦，天哪。不，打扫厨房是反女权主义的。在这个房间里，我们被母权社会包围着。确实如此。哦，你还真是。这墙上简直有裸体版画。这总是归结为性别。我戴着，像，裸体女性的耳环。
All right. Next question. All right. I asked that question. Maddie, your go. Oh, okay. So there was the... Was it not your go Meg?
这个播客的核心信息总是归结为性别。希望你们都在听。而且它超越了我们的框架。哦。这真的很好。耶。恭喜。
No, I had that. No. It is definitely my time. Maddie wants to go. There were a few questions. So we could do the... I did it around in 400. Oh yeah
好啦。下一个问题。好。我问了那个问题。Maddie，轮到你了。哦，好吧。所以有那个……难道不是轮到你了吗，Meg？
Oh the Oh no The music one Or the deaf versus blind community Or I feel like we can't really talk on that Because none of us are deaf or blind That's very true We're not we're a third party
不，我问过了。不。这绝对是我的时间。Maddie 想上。有几个问题。所以我们可以做这个……我大约在 400 左右做过。哦，对。
Yeah Well that's a question But that's not a question on the list I know exactly what question you're going to ask But is it a question? Question is like can we make commentary on like Things Well the government fucking does
哦，那个。哦，不。音乐那个。或者聋哑人群体对盲人群体。或者我觉得我们真的不能对此发表意见，因为我们既不是聋人也不是盲人。这倒是真的。我们不是，我们是第三方。
None of them are blind as deaf are they I, you know? Some of them might be. They have advisors. Okay, I thought about that. Okay, I thought about that while. They're not deaf or blind. Yes, what they call.
对。嗯，那是个问题。但那不在问题清单上。我确切地知道你要问什么问题。但那是个问题吗？问题就像是我们能否对政府他妈的在做的事情发表评论。
People that stand on behalf of people. Advocates. I found a good psychology question on the list. There is evidence that people give more to charity when asked by someone wearing a designer label. What should we make of this? What? What you mean?
他们当中没有人又盲又聋，对吧？我，你知道吗？他们当中可能有些人是。他们有顾问。好吧，我想过这个。好吧，我刚才想了一会儿。他们既不聋也不盲。是的，他们怎么称呼。
Like Gucci. Are they like saying that people with, I would immediately jump to you, are they saying that people with designer labels are more trustworthy? You know what I mean? Good. But why are they more trustworthy? Because they're rich. Yeah.
代表人们发声的人。倡导者。我在名单上找到了一个很好的心理学问题。有证据表明，当由穿着名牌服装的人提出要求时，人们会向慈善机构捐赠更多。我们该如何看待这一点？什么？你什么意思？
People have this stigma about. And is it like, oh well this rich person is asking me to give money to charity. So they probably give money to charity. And that's an indication of wealth. And I want to seem wealthy. And I want to seem wealthy. Yeah. I want more tax deductions.
像 Gucci 这样的。他们是在说，我会立刻联想到你，他们是在说穿名牌服装的人更值得信赖吗？你知道我的意思吗？好。但为什么他们更值得信赖？因为他们有钱。是的。
Yeah. I think Meg's point is really good. It's like if we see someone wearing nice clothes, we trust them, we believe that they'll be honest at our money. It's like our whole values in Australia and Western society are based on like success and money.
人们对这个有刻板印象。这就像是，哦，这个有钱人在让我为慈善机构捐款。所以他自己可能也向慈善机构捐了钱。这是财富的象征。而我想显得富有。而且我想显得富有。是的。我想要更多的税收抵免。
So many aspects are like that kind of concept. I feel like you can extrapolate to so many different aspects of life. It's kind of the same idea that underpins the whole it's not creepy if they're hot. Oh yeah. Or attractive people. do better in job interviews. There was a study in psychology.
是的。我觉得 Meg 的观点非常好。这就好收，如果我们看到有人穿着得体的衣服，我们会信任他们，我们相信他们会在我们的金钱问题上保持诚实。就像我们在澳大利亚和西方社会的整个价值观都是建立在成功和金钱的基础之上的。
I just learned that last week, actually. Yeah, attractive people do better in job interviews. Yeah, no, no, yeah. If you like, you know, video call attractive person, you trust them more because they're attractive. And so a designer label could be seen as attractive, like, more culturally because it's like, yes, an indication of wealth.
很多方面都类似于那种概念。我觉得你可以把它推广到生活的许多不同方面。这其实和那个支撑整个“只要长得好看就不能算变态”的观点是同一个道理。哦，对。或者有吸引力的人在求职面试中表现得更好。心理学上曾做过一项研究。
So you use such a big thing. You also look well around society. There was this Netflix show that I watched earlier this year called The Serpent, and it was about this guy that, like, murdered a bunch of backpackers in, like, He was hot. What was he? It wasn't that he was hot.
我上周刚学到这个，其实。对，有吸引力的人在求职面试中表现得更好。是的，不，不，是的。如果你喜欢，你知道的，通过视频通话跟一个有吸引力的人交流，你会更信任他们，因为他们很有吸引力。所以名牌服装可以被视为有吸引力的标志，在文化上更有吸引力，因为它是财富的象征。
It was that he was a fellow foreigner. And I feel like when you're traveling, you're in that group identity. You are more inclined to trust a fellow foreigner than you are a local person. And they were. But that's actually, I just had thought, apparently in Vietnam in Saigon. This is such a tangent.
所以你用了这么大的牌面。你在社会上也显得游刃有余。今年早些时候我看过一部 Netflix 电视剧叫《蛇蝎美男》（The Serpent），讲的是一个家伙，他谋杀了一群背包客，在，比如……他长得很帅。他是怎样的？关键不在于他长得帅。
No, I'm in Vietnam in Saigon. This is no, in any touristy area in like Southeast Asia or wherever, the touristy area is the one. where people get drinks parked it's not the local area because it's always the tourist area because people like oh they're fucking tourists like we're gonna dumb ass people yeah rich but they're so unaware of the culture around them at the moment but that's interesting because this is such designer clothes like maybe maybe if you've got someone in designer clothes asking you to give money it feels less like they're
关键在于他是一个同胞老乡。我觉得当你去旅游时，你身处那个群体认同中。比起当地人，你更有可能信任一个外国同胞。他们确实如此。但实际上，我刚刚想到，显然在越南西贡。这话题扯得太远了。
begging for money oh oh my god it's less like they don't need it but like oh my god that's so true that means it's like the the rich people always own the business you know i mean they're giving it to someone rich i don't know if makes sense but no i do i do know what you mean i was also going to say it's an idea of in groups and out groups so people who are wearing design i just thought that today people who are wearing like designer labels you form this kind of in group that a you also want to be a part of yeah you want to be a part of that a group you want to be rich yeah it's a whole western society you want to be rich again and a way that you can seem like you're part of the in group is by donating you know so that's
不，我在越南西贡。这不是——不，在东南亚或其他任何地方的旅游区，旅游区就是人们去买饮料的地方，而不是当地人的区域，因为旅游区总是这样，因为人们会想：“哦，他们他妈的是游客——我们要把这些蠢货当冤大头。”是的，有钱，但他们对周围的文化一无所知。但这就很有意思了，因为这就像是名牌服装——也许如果你有穿名牌服装的人要求你捐款，会让你觉得他们不那么像是在乞讨要钱。
Firstly, like the social pretense of wanting to appear wealthy. But secondly, it's the thing of like, I could be this person if I gave more generously. Like, I'm going to look like this individual if I give more generously. Like a very giving, like, generous. Or if rich people give, I'm going to give and then I'll be wealthy. Like, or, you know, I'll attract me. That's rude, not rude, but it's like the people, it's not the people who are being the, what do you call it, the advocates for these charities.
哦，哦天哪！这感觉不那么像他们自己需要钱，而是像——哦天哪，这太对了！这意味着，就像有钱人总是拥有企业一样，你知道我的意思吗？他们是把钱捐给某个有钱人。我不知道这讲不讲得通，但我确实——我确实知道你的意思。我本来还想说，这其实是内群体（in-groups）和外群体（out-groups）的概念，所以那些穿名牌的人——我今天刚想到这一点——那些穿着名牌服装的人，你会自然而然地形成一种内群体，而你也是其中一员。
It's not their fault, but like, like, they're calling on individuals like us who are definitely not rich people. Like, they're billionaires that could donate like 1,000 times that what we could donate. But they call upon, like, individuals like us. You know, you see people in the, you know, like, I don't know, like World Vision in the supermarket in Civic, you know? And they're calling on people like us. Should that be a maximum income. Oh, no, no, okay, I just had a really good idea. Oh, my God.
你也想成为其中的一部分。是的，你想成为那个群体的一部分，你想变得富有。是的，整个西方社会都想变得富有。而你可以让自己看起来像是内群体一员的一种方式，就是通过捐款，你知道的。所以首先，这是一种想要显得富有的社会虚荣。但其次，这也是一种“如果我能更慷慨地捐款，我也能成为这样的人”的心态。就像“如果我慷慨解囊，我就会看起来像这个人”。就像一个非常给予的、慷慨的人。或者如果富人捐款，我也捐款，然后我就会变得富有。或者，你知道的，我会吸引我。这有点粗鲁——也不是粗鲁，但这就好像是那些人，那些不是——那些人不是慈善机构的倡导者，
Okay. another facet, if they're wearing designer labels, it makes the company look more trustworthy because it makes them look more professional. It makes them look like they know how to spend their money more. It makes them look more capable because if their employees or the people who are asking for money look like those that are a symbol of wealth
这不是他们的错，但是，他们号召像我们这样绝对算不上富有的人。像那些亿万富翁，他们可以捐出比我们多1000倍的钱，他们却去号召像我们这样的个人。你知道的，你会看到人们在——你知道的，就像在市民广场（Civic）超市里的世界宣明会（World Vision），你知道吗？他们在号召像我们这样的人。这难道不应该有个最高收入限制吗？哦，不，不，好吧，我刚刚有了一个非常好的主意。哦，天哪。
and a symbol of doing well, you might think, like, are they actually know what they're doing because if this rich person is supporting them, a rich person isn't going to waste their money. But then I would think, like, If I saw someone working for like, I don't know, what's a good, what's a good vision? Yeah, like, and they were wearing designer clothes, I'd be like, wow, fast fashion. Yeah.
好吧。另一个方面，如果他们穿着名牌服装，这会使公司看起来更值得信赖，因为它让公司显得更专业。这让他们看起来更懂得如何支配资金。这让他们看起来更有能力，因为如果他们的员工或那些募捐的人看起来是财富的象征、是混得很好的象征，你可能会想：“哦，他们其实知道自己在做什么吗？因为如果这个有钱人在支持他们，有钱人是不会浪费自己的钱的。”但随后我又会想，如果我看到有人为——我不知道，什么是好的，什么是好的宣明会？
Are these clothes made sustainable? I'd actually trust someone who's wearing, like, not, like, who was still clean, but who was wearing, like, ethically made clothes. Yeah. Like, secondhand clothes. Because I'll be, oh, my God, they actually care, like, you know, about fast, not this is about fast fashion. But, you know, about, like, that's still in, in, in, I know, what's a word, like, less, economically developed countries.
是的，就像，如果他们穿着名牌服装，我会想：“哇，快时尚。”是的。这些衣服是可持续制造的吗？我其实会更信任那些穿着——不是，那种虽然穿得很干净，但穿着符合伦理道德制造的衣服的人。是的。比如二手衣服。因为我会想：“哦，天哪，他们实际上是在关心，你知道的，关于快时尚——倒不是说这是关于快时尚的，而是关于——那仍然在——在——在，我懂的，那个词叫什么来着，比如经济欠发达国家。”
I think it's all about appearances and what appearance of the company attracts, like what you're attracted to. What the audience is of the company's advertising. If you want a company that you think is trustworthy or like if you want one that seems ethical, like how do you navigate that in terms of presenting
我觉得这一切都关乎外表，以及公司的外表能吸引什么——也就是你会被什么所吸引。这家公司的广告受众是谁。如果你想要一家你认为值得信赖的公司，或者如果你想要一家看起来很有道德的公司，在展现品牌形象方面，你该如何驾驭这一点？
a brand? What was a question? Sorry. Oh, I completely forgot. What was the question? Sorry, Maddie. We went on a big. No, no, that's fine. It wasn't one that I initiated. kind of flagged to do but then it popped up and I thought oh that's a bit of
刚才的问题是什么来着？抱歉。哦，我完全忘了。刚才的问题是什么？抱歉，Maddie。我们扯得太远了。不，不，没关系。那不是我主动挑起的话题。我本来只是顺便提了一下，但它突然冒出来，然后我想“哦，这有点心理学意味”。
psychology it was yes no it was why are we more likely to donate to charity when we're asked by people wearing to try and clothes oh that it does relate to what we're saying and I thought we're one of complete tangent that we are on the right track we've still to do with charity we were kind of yeah but I think that's a really interesting one when was the last time you guys donated to charity I used to do were like monthly they conned me into doing a monthly thing to the wilderness society oh i knew you were going to say the wilderness society they fucking con me and they like i was like they like do five dollars i was like yeah and then he didn't say it was five
是的，不，就是为什么当穿着得体衣服的人向我们要求时，我们更有可能向慈善机构捐款？哦，这确实和我们刚才说的话有关，我还以为我们扯到十万八千里去了呢。其实我们还在正轨上，这仍然跟慈善有关，我们刚刚在——是的，但我觉得这是一个非常有趣的问题。你们上一次向慈善机构捐款是什么时候？我以前是那种按月——他们诱导我加入了一个针对荒野协会（Wilderness Society）的月捐计划。哦，我就知道你要说荒野协会。他们他妈的诱导了我，他们就像——我说“捐5块钱吧”，然后他们没说那是比我原本要付的钱还要多5块钱，所以我最后付了15块钱，然后我就——
dollars more than what i was paying so i paid fifteen dollars and i was like and then i rang up but i had to ring up because i couldn't do it online and then they made you feel mad yes probably i can't and i was like i can't afford it i'm a student like i always use that though because i'm like well i'm a fucking billion i'm a student oh when Darwin went into like the snap lockdown when I was home and the fringe comedy festival that was the week after got kind of preemptively cancelled and they gave you the offer to donate the money from your tickets to charity and my friend bought like $300 by the ticket she was saying and she was like yeah yeah I'll donate it and then a couple of days later her car broke down
然后我打电话过去，但我必须打电话，因为我没法在网上取消。然后他们让你觉得很内疚。是的，可能吧，我做不到。我当时就想：“我付不起，我还是个学生——”不过我总是用这个借口，因为我想：“好吧，我他妈是个亿万——我只是个学生。”哦，当达尔文市进入突然封城时，当时我在家，而一周后举行的边缘喜剧节（Fringe Comedy Festival）被提前取消了，他们提供了一个选项，可以把你门票的钱捐给慈善机构。我朋友买的票花了大约300多美元，她当时就说：“行吧行吧，我捐了。”结果几天后她的车抛锚了。
Oh no. So she emailed them. Oh, that money back. Fair enough. No. Honestly. You retract my joke. They're like, sorry, like a struggling artist has already spent that.
哦，不。所以她发邮件给他们。哦，要求退钱。这也情有可原。不。说实话。你收回你的笑话。他们大概会说：“抱歉，苦命的艺术家已经把钱花光了。”
Yeah. I've decided that I'm really, I want to, self-interest. Yeah. Adam Smith, maybe he's right. Oh, fuck. I remember, the one that really gets me is Doctors Without Borders. I've heard that. Is that many, what do you go?
好吧，我决定了，我真的很想——自私自利。是的。亚当·斯密，也许他是对的。哦，操。我记得，真正让我抓狂的是无国界医生组织（Doctors Without Borders）。我听说过这个。那是许多——你怎么说？
Many song songs. Yeah. I don't speak French. Yeah, it's, because it's... Medic on Francierge. No, it's Medique Saint-Frontier. Okay. I think.
Mendic... 许多歌曲。对。我不会说法语。对，那是，因为它是……Medecins Sans Frontieres。不，是 Medecins Sans Frontieres。好吧。我想是吧。
Medicine on the front. Medici Saint-Frontier. Yeah, that's it. Maddie's like, I don't know. She'll say it in Chinese and I'm not really... Yeah, I'll say it in Russian. You say it in Arabic. She'll say it in Chinese.
前线的医生。Medecins Sans Frontieres。对，就是这个。Maddie 的表情就像是“我不知道”。她会用中文说，而我其实——是的，我会用俄语说。你用阿拉伯语说。她会用中文说。
We love that. And we can just all show off. I feel like this could really lead well into the other question that was... Oh, yeah. The other question that was... Oh, yeah, but can I just... Yes, yeah, but I just want to say, if you haven't want to donate, you should definitely donate to Doctors Without Borders because their ad campaign videos get me every fucking time. I literally will watch them if I want to.
我们太喜欢这样了。然后我们就可以尽情显摆了。我觉得这可以很好地过渡到另一个问题……哦，对。另一个问题是……哦，对，但是我可以——是的，是的，但我只是想说，如果你还没想好捐给谁，你绝对应该捐给无国界医生组织，因为他们的广告宣传视频每次都能狠狠戳中我。如果我想——我真的会看它们的。
I know, I know, I know, but... This is the podcast. Okay, sponsor me. Okay, next. I got to make from us. Your question. There was... Or the happy one or not...
我知道，我知道，我知道，但是……这是播客。好吧，来赞助我吧。好的，下一个。该我们出了。你的问题。有……或者那个快乐的，还是不……
Oh, multi. Did, or the multi-legal. Yeah, that one's good. I feel like that could segue well from... Guys, we're only like 36 minutes in. We have heaps of time. Well, we're definitely getting indebted. to all souls.
哦，多语言。或者那个多法律的。对，那个挺好的。我觉得那个可以很好地顺着——伙计们，我们才录了36分钟。我们有的是时间。好吧，我们肯定会欠一屁股债的。
Wait. All Souls? What's All Souls? This is a college. Oh, Gemma. I don't even know what it's called. I'm obviously not fucking getting in. No, you're not.
等等。All Souls（万灵学院）？什么是 All Souls？这是一个学院。哦，Gemma。我甚至不知道它叫什么。我显然他妈的考不进去。不，你当然考不进去。
Hang on, I need to find it. No, the question was, is... Does multilingualism mean multiple identities? Boom. Boom. And I think, well, I said that because, well, we all speak different languages. Yeah. Definitely being in a different country.
等等，我得找找。不，问题是，多语言意味着多个身份吗？砰。砰。我觉得，嗯，我这么说是因为，嗯，我们所有人都会说不同的语言。对。身处不同的国家绝对是这样。
Yeah. Like, you can't take. on like it was French you like take on the accent it's like the whole vibe you need the accent otherwise you can't if you speak French without the accent so why is the accent you're not speaking because it's like you don't like you can't yeah they're snobby you can't if you don't speak the accent you're not for it's like what the fuck is this person doing they're like just we megan like you just say it like nicely that's part of the identity yeah it's part of the identity exactly what was that no but this morning there was actually like 1400
对。就像，你不能像——如果是法语，你就得带上口音，这就好像是整个氛围，你必须得有口音，否则你就不能——如果你说法语没有口音，那还算什么口音？你根本不算在说，因为这就好像你不会——对，他们很势利，如果你不说出那个口音，你就不算数。这就像是“这人到底在干嘛？”他们就像是——我们，Megan，你只要把它说得好听点就行了。那是身份的一部分。是的，这正是身份的一部分。刚才那是——没有，但今天早上其实有大约1400个
Carol. I'm currently. Oh, there was. Yeah, it was Carlin'am central this morning. Did you mean go? I did, yes. And Jazz was asleep. I was like, surely Jazz is going to wake up. I don't know, there's one there, there's one. There's one. Every, northeast, southwest. Never took a weekbeaks. Anyway. Oh, very good. But I remember when I used to speak,
卡林（Carol）。我目前。哦，确实有。对，今天早上到处都是卡林姆中心（Carlin'am central）。你是说 Go 吗？我是说 Go。而且 Jazz 还睡着呢。我当时想：“Jazz 肯定快醒了。”我不知道，那边有一个，这里有一个。有一个。每个，东北，西南。从没拿过威比奖（Webby）。无论如何。哦，非常好。但我记得我以前说，
when I was in Russia, I would, like, my Russian was so Australian. So I'd be like, I would just use, like, I would just say, I would just say, I would just say, like, I, what you meant say is, I'm going to say, but I would say, yeah, but I would say, yeah, Gavarayu, Peruski. Yeah, but you don't know until you go over there, because I went French before I went over,
当我在俄罗斯时，我会——我的俄语听起来太澳大利亚了。所以我就会像——我只会用，我只会说，我只会说，我只会说，就像，我，你的意思是，我会说，但我会说，对，但我会说，对，Govaryu, Russki。是的，但你没去那儿之前是不会知道的，因为我出发前学过法语，
and I was like, so Australian, but when I went over, I was like, fuck, why am I saying this? So are you both saying that the different identity would come from the different accent? I feel like it's indicative of the different identity you step into when you go to that culture. But language is literally interconnected with identity. I did see you 12, and I stick by it.
我当时觉得自己好澳大利亚啊，但当我到了那里之后，我心想：“操，我为什么这么说话？”所以你们俩的意思是，不同的身份来自于不同的口音？我觉得这暗示了当你进入那种文化时，你所代入的的不同身份。但语言与身份是息息相关的。我上12年级时就这么认为，而且我至今坚持这个观点。
How, look, you've got to explain it. Okay, I didn't go that well in English, but I can try to explain it. No, it's just like the words we use, the syntax, the semantics, the meaning behind everything we say. Like, like, Ozzy, it's like, we shorten things and that, that in its way, it's like we say like Smokoe and we say like servo or whatever. And that in its way is like, we're like lazy. We are. We're lazy and we're like, or casual. Yeah, casual and lazy, I think. In a general, like, very generalized stereotypical way. But like, compared to like,
怎么说，听着，你得解释一下。好吧，我英语考得不是很好，但我可以试着解释一下。不，这就像我们使用的词汇、句法、语义，我们所说的一切背后的含义。比如，像 Aussie，就像，我们喜欢缩写，而这种方式，就像我们说 Smokoe，我们说 servo 或者别的什么。这种方式就显得我们很懒。我们确实很懒。我们很懒，而且显得——或者很随性。对，既随性又懒散，我觉得。以一种非常笼统、非常刻板的方式。但是，相比之下，
Like, yeah, French, where it's like... Eloquent. Yeah, like, it sounds beautiful. And, like, you... All these, like, you say these sayings, like, these phrases. And because you say these, you know, like metaphors, you sound more, yeah, eloquent, more, like, fancy. And maybe that's a part of...
比如，法语，听起来就像……雄辩。对，听起来很美妙。而且，你……所有这些，你知道的，你说的那些俗语，那些短语。正因为你说了这些，你知道的，比如隐喻，你听起来就更，是的，更有说服力，更花哨。也许这也是一部分……
I feel like it is... You do have different identities. Because it's, like, what you... The language really shows what people value in that culture. And even the way of, like, forming sentences. I also feel like when you step into a different culture and you speak a different language, you start to identify with different people.
我觉得确实如此……你确实拥有不同的身份。因为这就像，你所使用的语言真正展现了那种文化中的人们珍视什么。甚至包括组织句子的方式。我还觉得，当你踏入不同的文化并说不同的语言时，你开始认同不同的人。
And just by inherent nature, you'd start to identify with people of different backgrounds and of different cultural values. Are you okay, Maddie? You're bit uncomfortable. I'm getting bit hot. Oh, me too. We should turn the heater down.
仅凭天性，你就会开始认同那些有着不同背景和不同文化价值观的人。你还好吗，Maddie？你看起来有点不舒服。我有点热。哦，我也是。我们应该把暖气调小点。
Maddie you're close. We're sitting next to the heater guys. No, but actually, that's a weird example because, like, in the Arab world, it's beauty for women is very big. Like, it's like, well, to be fair, like, there isn't much natural, like, outdoorsy stuff, which was what I would usually be into.
Maddie，你离得最近。我们正坐在暖气旁边呢，伙计们。不，但实际上，这是一个奇怪的例子，因为在阿拉伯世界，女性的美丽是非常重要的事情。就像，好吧，平心而论，那里并没有太多天然的、户外的活动，而这通常是我比较喜欢的。
So even like the, when I was over there, I like, obviously, I don't, I actually do like anyone else done and stuff. But I like, I would love them like, like, everyone vibes getting their nails done. Everyone vibes having their hair and makeup really nice. I was like, I can actually do this. And I don't, like, I, in Australia, I love to go in the outdoors. And I love to be, you know, like, all this sporty stuff. Then when I was in the Arab, when I was in Jordan, I was like, oh, I can, like, I can't do that because there's no option to do that.
所以即使在——当我待在那儿的时候，我——显然，我其实并不——我也像其他人一样做美甲什么的。但我喜欢——我喜欢那种，每个人都喜欢做指甲的氛围。每个人都喜欢把头发和妆容弄得美美的。我当时想：“我其实也能做到这一点。”而且我并不——在澳大利亚，我喜欢去户外。我喜欢进行所有这些运动类的东西。然后当我身处阿拉伯——当我在约旦时，我想：“哦，我能——我不能那样做，因为没有那种选项。”我会融入他们的文化，然后去做我的发型。
I'll go to their culture and I'll do my hair. who was a gateway into accessing that. Yeah, I know. It was just like... You feel more immersed in it and therefore you feel more like... Yeah. All right, Maddie actually lived in China for a while,
这成为了接触那种文化的一个切入点。是的，我懂。这就像是……你会觉得更沉浸其中，因此你会感觉更像——是的。好吧，Maddie 实际上在中国住过一段时间，
so let's talk about her to her. So we've all lived in the countries that we speak a language of. So I feel like it's kind of difficult because then when you're back in Australia, I have not spoken Russian to anyone for about a year. It's so hard because the context around you is Australian. Yeah. No one speaks Russian here.
所以让我们跟她聊聊。我们都曾在我们所说语言的国家生活过。所以我觉得这有点困难，因为当你回到澳大利亚时，我已经大约有一年没和任何人说过俄语了。这太难了，因为你周围的语境是澳大利亚的。是的。这里没有人说俄语。
I feel like when I first lived in China and I didn't speak good Chinese at this point, and the job that I had in Guangzhou back in 2017, I was the only foreigner there. And something that I really struggled with linguistically was when people would ask me to do things in Chinese and the requests sound much more direct in Chinese than they do in English because in English we tend.
我觉得当我第一次住在中国时，那时候我的中文还不好，我在2017年广州的那份工作，我是那里唯一的外国人。我在语言上真正挣扎的一点是，当人们用中文要求我做事情时，中文中的请求听起来比英语中要直接得多，因为在英语中我们倾向于……
There's no please or thank you, isn't it? Yeah, you don't use please and thank you as often. And Chinese doesn't have as many, filler one. Oh yes, the fillers like, yeah, yeah, and in English, I think we really, we really, we really, and especially women, we love to hedge our language. Oh, hedging. I'm really sorry, I'm sorry to bother you, but if you have time, could you maybe possibly, please do this, if you got a chance. Rather like, do this. But something I also really thought about. And just on the accent topic quickly with like Chinese, I think it's a whole
没有“请”或“谢谢”，对吧？是的，你不会那么频繁地使用“请”和“谢谢”。而且中文也没有那么多填充词。哦，对，像那些填充词，是的，是的，在英语中，我觉得我们真的——我们真的，尤其是女性，我们喜欢在语言中留有退路。哦，留退路（hedging）。“非常抱歉，打扰一下，但如果你有时间，能不能也许、可能，请做一下这个，如果你有机会的话。”而不是直接说：“把这个做了。”但我也深思过的一点是。顺便快速谈一下关于中文口音的话题，我觉得那完全是另一码事，因为它是一种声调语言，所以这就好比如果你没有说得过去的口音，你根本——你实际上就无法被听懂。是的，你做不到。所以掌握这门语言意味着你确实拥有不同的身份，否则你就无法与人交流，所以这就好像你必须——是因为如果没有口音你就没法说这门语言吗？基本上就是这门语言，或者——是的，至少拥有——我觉得，当它是声调语言时，你在发音上的灵活性要小得多。
different ball game there because it's a tonal language so it's kind of like if you don't have somewhat of a good accent you're completely like you actually don't understood yeah you can't so being adopting the language means that like you do have a different identity because otherwise you can't communicate with people so it's like you have to is it because you can't speak the language without having the accent basically the language or yeah at least having I think I think you have less flexibility with your pronunciation when it's a tonal language. Yeah.
然后你会想，他们是怎么想的？就像，你知道我的意思吗？比如，法国人会怎么想？哦，当我们说澳洲味儿的法语时？他们会觉得——这是什么鬼？哦，当他们听到澳大利亚英语时，对。但我想，他们大概只会那么想吧。他们能听懂，但会想：这到底是什么鬼？
And then you think what do they think? Like, you know what I mean? Like, what do French people mean? Oh, when we speak Aussie French? Like, do they like, what the fuck? Oh, when they hear Australian English, yeah. But I suppose like, they would just think of it. They could understand it, like, what the fuck is this?
然后你会想，他们是怎么想的？就像，你知道我的意思吗？就像，法国人是怎么想的？哦，当我们说澳洲法语时？就像，他们会想，这特么是什么鬼？哦，当他们听到澳大利亚英语时，是的。但我想，他们可能只是这么想的。他们能听懂，就像，这特么到底是什么鬼？
But actually, can I say this about what you were saying, like when you go to France or when I was in, like, Russia and, you know, the accent was such a huge part? Perhaps people who are speaking French or people who are speaking Russian who come to Australia are equally, like oh my god I feel like I can't actually get into this culture because the Aussies have such a strange accent that's why I'm so important to travel and like understand that because we all understand like if a French if like a you know
但其实，关于你刚才说的，比如当你去法国，或者像我在俄罗斯时，你知道的，口音占据了很大一部分？也许那些说法语或俄语并来到澳大利亚的人也会觉得，天哪，我觉得自己根本融入不了这种文化，因为澳洲人的口音太奇怪了，这就是为什么我觉得旅行并理解这一点如此重要，因为我们都明白，如果一个法国人，或者你知道的
whoever like a international person came to Australia will be like oh that's so like they're speaking English like that's amazing you know but they're like I can't understand Aussies like I often got that was like when I was in Russia like people couldn't understand my English like sometimes even though they spoke English it's English It was American or American. Yeah, that's a big problem. And then I'd be there, like, heavy on the vowels. It's as much as a dialogue.
随便什么国际友人来到澳大利亚，我们会觉得，哦，太棒了，他们在说英语，这太神奇了，你知道的，但他们会说，我听不懂澳洲人的英语——我经常遇到这种情况，比如我在俄罗斯的时候，人们听不懂我的英语——有时候即使他们会说英语，那也是美式英语。对，这是个大问题。然后我在那里说话时元音发得很重。这就像是一场对话。
Interesting. A bit of nasal pronoun. Nasal, yeah. Do you find, because whenever I go back to Queensland, my Australian accent, just like, that's what, like, no, I noticed when my brother went to Queensland when you came back, his accent was so, Queensland. I was like, get out.
有趣。有点带鼻音。鼻音，对。你有没有发现，每当我回昆士兰时，我的澳洲口音就会——就像，那就是，不，我注意到我弟弟去昆士兰回来后，他的口音太“昆士兰”了。我当时就想，滚开。
Did you notice that when we were in Queensland? Was my accent stronger, or did you not really notice? I didn't notice. Well, you're going to say, Maddie, you had a point. I saw you're opening on my mic. Oh, another thing I wanted... Back down. Yes.
我们在昆士兰的时候你注意到了吗？我的口音更重了，还是你根本没注意到？我没注意到。好吧，你本来想说，麦迪，你刚才有个观点。我看到你在麦克风前欲言又止了。哦，还有件事我想……退后。对。
Back down. To the ground. Drop it low. No, another thing that I find really interesting about Chinese, particularly now that we're having a huge conversation about pronouns is that in spoken Chinese, there is no differentiation between men and women. Everyone is Ta. Is that you or is that he or she?
退后。到地上。蹲低。不，我发现关于中文还有一个非常有趣的地方，特别是现在我们在大肆讨论代词的时候，在口语中文里，男和女是没有区别的。每个人都是“他（tā）”。这是你，还是他或她？
He, she. Oh, really? That is cool. because Arabic is the complete opposite. Yeah, it's everyone is tar. It's only when you write, like, and you want to say tar, blah, blah, blah, as in a woman, that you use a different, you use a female radical. And interestingly, when you use the tar character for a man,
他，她。哦，真的吗？这太酷了。因为阿拉伯语完全相反。对，每个人都是“tar”。只有当你写字的时候，比如你想写“tar”（某个女性），诸如此类，才会用不同的字，你会用一个女性偏旁。有趣的是，当你用“他”这个字来指代男性时，
it's not a male radical, it is the person radical. Because man is the default human. And when you say they in Chinese... Wait, is man the default human in Chinese? Or are you talking about... In general. In general. In Chinese, what's the default human?
它用的不是男性偏旁，而是单人旁。因为男人是默认的人类。当你在中文里说“他们”时……等等，男人在中文里是默认的人类吗？还是你在说……总体而言。总体而言。在中文里，什么是默认的人类？
Is it person? Like, you know what I mean? If you were referring to, like, what's that object over there? So, say it's a chair, would you say that most objects are male? Or it. Or it. Their it. Oh, it's so good.
是“人”吗？就像，你知道我的意思吗？如果你在指代，比如，那边那个是什么东西？假设是一张椅子，你会说大多数物体都是男性化的吗？或者“它”。或者“它”。它们的“它”。哦，这太棒了。
And Chinese is not gendered, but the it is also tar. Oh, yeah, but a different character. That's a different character. But also, you don't use that word that often in Chinese, because Chinese doesn't, you don't really repeat the subject after it's been mentioned for the first time. So that doesn't really arise. But when you want to say like they and you use the tar character plus the character that indicates like
而且中文虽然不分性别，但“它”也是“tā”。哦，对，不过是不同的字。那是不同的字。而且，在中文里你其实不经常用那个词，因为中文里——一旦在第一次提到之后，你其实不会真正重复主语。所以这个问题实际上不会出现。但是当你想要表达“他们”时，你使用“他”这个字，再加上表示
the plurality, you use the male tar character and something as well, words like jealousy in Chinese, that has a female radical. And I think that's interesting. So back to cultural identity, though, if that shapes the way you think about gender. But English, yeah, that's good. That's actually been research quite like a lot.
复数的那个字，你用的是男性的“他”字加上一些其他东西。比如中文里的“嫉妒”这类词，就带有女性偏旁。我觉得这很有意思。所以回到文化认同上，如果这塑造了你对性别的思考方式的话。不过英语，对，这很好。这其实已经被研究得很多了。
It's like the genders of certain nouns. Based on, oh, yeah, how language shapes to your perspective. Because English doesn't have genders, does it? Not really. Like, you say like vehicles are she's. And, you know, like, only that sense. No, but it isn't like, you know, like. Like lamp over there, I'm still going to be a lamp.
比如某些名词的性别。基于，哦，对，语言是如何塑造你的视角的。因为英语没有语法性别，对吧？其实没有。比如，你会把交通工具称为“她”。而且，你知道的，仅限那种情况。不对，但它不像，你知道的。比如那边那盏灯，我还是会觉得它是灯。
It doesn't change. It's not her, you know. Like in Italian, like, lamp might be feminine. Yeah, in French. French, yeah, or like whatever, and I don't know, like the radical or whatever. Yeah. But, like, English doesn't have it, but then English, I feel like every English-speaking country, there's definitely gender issues.
它不会变。它不是“她”，你知道吗。就像在意大利语里，灯可能是阴性的。对，在法语里。法语，对，或者诸如此类，我不知道，比如词根什么的。对。但是，英语里没有这个，然而英语里，我觉得在每一个讲英语的国家，绝对都存在性别问题。
Yeah. But I know, I searched up, what are the matriarchies, I remember this, what are the matriarchies in, like, the world? Yeah. And I can't remember, but there was one in, like, Tibet, the kind of China area. I just remember that. Like, somewhere there, there was, like, a huge matriarchy society. Yeah.
对。但我知道，我查过，世界上有哪些母系社会，我记得这个，世界上有哪些母系社会？对。虽然我记不清了，但有一个在西藏那边，也就是中国周边地区。我只记得这个。就像在那里的某个地方，有一个庞大的母系社会。对。
It's one in East Africa as well. Yeah. Yeah, like it's interesting. It'd be really cool as a psych, kind of talking more about psychology, like, and linguistics and the intersection between linguistics and even sociology, like doing a triple discipline on this, on this topic. It's always, like, always, hips of fun, but, like, it would be really, really interesting to think about perspectives on gender and respect around gender and gender hierarchy
东非也有一个。对。对，这很有意思。作为一个心理学专业的人，如果能把心理学、语言学以及语言学和社会学的交叉领域结合起来，探讨这三个学科的交汇点，深入这个话题，那一定非常酷。这总是——总是充满乐趣，但是，思考人们对性别的看法、对性别的尊重以及性别等级制度，会是非常非常有趣的事，
based on how language treats it, which kind of comes into cultural identity, like. Oh, yeah, it's so interconnected. Yeah. The language you used is, like we were talking about with the deaf-blind thing, language is primarily your main mode of communication. And it becomes almost unconscious and implicit. So if your language is treating a gender in a certain way, even just in its semantics, how does that translate?
这些看法取决于语言是如何对待性别的，这在某种程度上涉及到文化认同。哦，对，它们是如此紧密相连。对。你使用的语言，就像我们之前讨论聋盲人的情况一样，语言主要就是你主要的沟通方式。它变得几乎是无意识的和内隐的。所以，如果你的语言以某种特定方式对待性别，哪怕只是在语义上，这又是如何转化的呢？
Or where did that come from? Like in Russian, it's like, oh my God, it's just like everything is gendered. Everything is gendered. If I touch an object, it's a female object now. Like they is a, in Arabic. It's they she or they her. But then the distinction between genders is so much stronger. Yeah.
或者这源于何处？就像在俄罗斯语里，天哪，简直是万物皆有性别。万物皆有性别。如果我摸了一个物体，它现在就是一个女性物体。就像在阿拉伯语里“他们”是。是“他们（阴性）”或“他们（她）”。但性别之间的区别要强烈得多。对。
But how would you, if you were like, what's the word, non-binary, like, you couldn't, any other languages, that's just another thing. How would you become, you wouldn't have an identity in another language. Yeah. You're not a, you're not a, you're not like a, or in Chinese, yes, but in Arabic and Russian. You're not, you're not a they. Like, there's no, you can't be that, you can't be, you can't be, you can't.
但是，如果你处于那种情况，怎么说呢，比如非二元性别，你根本无法——在其他语言里，那是另一回事。你在另一种语言里根本不会拥有这种身份认同。对。你不是一个，你不是一个，你不是一个，或者在中文里可以，但在阿拉伯语和俄语里。你不是，你不是一个“他们”。就像，没有这种说法，你不能成为那样，你不能，你不能。
Yeah, you're either plural or inanimate. That's really hard for our, like, growing world though. growing world though because like how how are people who are non-binary or that is their identity fit in with that cultural background it's very historical language is a very historical you would definitely get into oxford college with that response that was funny list yeah that was so fucking true was it oh my god myself you know it was really interesting i did not even think about that you have to re-listen to this because i forgot oh yeah anytime you need a bit of a positivity i am a genius yeah how don't we just send this to
对，要么是复数，要么是无生命的事物。不过这对于我们这个不断发展的世界来说真的很难。不过，对于不断发展的世界来说，那些非二元性别的人，或者拥有这种身份认同的人，该如何融入那种文化背景呢？这非常历史化。语言是一个非常历史化的……你凭这种回答绝对能进牛津大学。刚才太搞笑了，丽丝。对，那真是太真实了。是不是？天哪，我真佩服我自己，你知道的，这真的很有趣，我甚至都没想到这一点。你得重新听一遍这一段，因为我忘了。哦，对，任何时候当你需要一点正能量时，我就是个天才。对，我们为什么不直接把这个发给
would and be like here you go what are your thoughts yeah give me like some constructive three PhDs so yeah funded fully yeah yeah one for each of us yeah and I would like to work on I don't know I don't think I would do climate change it's too big what would you okay wait kind of an interstate like a bit of a movement away what would you do your PhD on in if you could in the next five years maybe fires in Australia something to do with bushfires something so it's something local that Yeah, what would you do your PhD on? Or gender?
伍德，然后说：“给你，你怎么看？”对，给我几个建设性的意见。三个博士学位，所以，对，完全资助，对，对，我们每人一个，对。而我想研究的是，我不知道，我觉得我不会去研究气候变化，这太宏大了。你呢，等一下，有点像——稍微偏离一下话题，如果你能在接下来的五年里攻读博士学位，你会研究什么？也许是澳大利亚的森林大火，某种与森林大火相关的东西，总之是一些本土的东西。对，你会攻读什么博士学位？或者性别？
They're so... Gender, yeah. That's so, it's so hard to narrow down. I think I'm really interested in social media and democracy, but I'm also really interested in, you know, the Australia-China space. Is the Belt and Road a new form of imperialism? I don't know what that means. I would do my PhD on.
这些太……性别，对。这太难缩小范围了。我觉得我对社交媒体和民主很感兴趣，但我也对澳大利亚和中国的关系很感兴趣。一带一路是帝国主义的新形式吗？我不知道那是什么意思。这就是我会用来写博士论文的题目。
false memories and the prevalence of false memories but then I also is there such thing as a true memory no no there is absolutely no there is absolutely no okay don't think much yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry um psychology I could not do my it's just sociology psychology I would just my brain is how is it as a psychology student do you find it hard to navigate the duality of um kind of having that elevated self-awareness of why you think the way that you do and what kind of like thinking traps you're susceptible to and at the same time still being susceptible to them you know what it really sucks because you would think so this is the thing with unconscious processes being aware of them doesn't actually do anything so I have this issue all the time is it like
虚假记忆以及虚假记忆的普遍性。但随后我也会想，真的存在所谓的“真实记忆”吗？没有，绝对没有。绝对没有。好吧，别想太多。对不起，对不起，嗯，心理学，我没法做我的，这只是社会学，心理学，我只是……我的大脑是……作为一个心理学专业的学生，你是否觉得很难驾驭这种二元性？一方面对自己的思考方式以及自己容易陷入什么样的思维陷阱有着高度的自我觉察，而另一方面却又同时无法摆脱这些陷阱？你知道吗，这真的很糟，因为你可能会以为——这就是无意识过程的问题所在，意识到它们其实根本没用。所以我一直有这个问题。这是……
involuntary yeah it's involuntary absolutely I get stuck in thinking traps all the time like and I know why they occur I know like it's really crazy because I've got into my therapist office and she'll be like and she'll tell you why it happens but you can't but I'm like like I already I already know like she'll be like oh we should do this and I'm like yeah but like the other day she was like we should do DET and I was a dialectical emotional therapy and I was like oh but I know that it has this downside and it's actually not going to work for me because I know that this is an issue with it and actually I didn't have this background so talking about it will actually be worse for me and she's but it's very that's very specific that's like a one-line
身不由己的吗？对，这是身不由己的，绝对的。我总是陷入思维陷阱，而且我知道它们为什么会发生，我知道——这真的很疯狂，因为我去治疗师办公室时，她会——她会告诉你为什么会这样，但你却无法……但我总是像——我早就知道了。比如她会说：“哦，我们应该这样做。”我会说：“对，但是……”比如前几天她说：“我们应该尝试DBT（辩证行为疗法）。”我说：“哦，但我知道这有缺点，这实际上对我不适用，因为我知道这其中存在一个问题，而且由于我没有这种背景，所以谈论它实际上对我更糟糕。”她说，但这是非常具体的，这就像是一行
thing you know what I mean like every individual is yeah or intrusive thoughts as well and like I know exactly why I'm getting intrusive thoughts I know exactly and all the the process behind it but like I still get them. That is a two-edged sword again. Yeah, it kind of sucks. Yeah. Or like my OCD as well. That's like the whole thing about I always, I think this all the time and I know it's quite like I would say it's not privilege but just like privilege in the fact that I have like we all have quite big brains, you know? Big brains. Big brains. Big brains. Maddie has a tiny head though. So really? I feel like I have a big head. Medium head, I would say.
代码，你知道我的意思吗？就像每个人都是……或者还有侵入性思维，我确切地知道为什么我会产生侵入性思维，我确切地知道背后的整个过程，但我还是会产生这些想法。这又是一把双刃剑。对，这有点糟糕。对，或者比如我的强迫症也是。这就是那种整件事……我总是这样想，而且我知道这相当——我会说这不是特权，只是我们在某种事实上拥有特权，我们的大脑都挺聪明的，你知道吗？聪明的大脑。聪明的大脑。聪明的大脑。不过麦迪的头很小。真的吗？我觉得我的头挺大的。中等大小的头吧，我觉得。
Mine's pretty big. Yours is big, Gemma, yeah. I was fat head. I don't. My parents used to call me a square. I used to have a square head. My parents used to tease me. Wait, wait, what was the privilege?
我的挺大的。你的很大，杰玛，对。我以前是个大头。我不是。我父母以前管我叫方头。我以前有个方脑袋。我父母以前总拿这个取笑我。等等，等等，刚才说的特权是什么？
Yeah, it's like, would you rather, this is, I don't think this is a very ethical question, so probably wouldn't be on that question, on that board exam. But like, would you rather be, I think I've said this. Oh, my God, we've told about this. Intelligent and have mental health, anxiety issues,
对，就像是，你宁愿……这是一个，我觉得这不太是一个符合伦理的问题，所以大概不会出现在期末考试的卷子上。但是，就像，你愿意成为……我觉得我好像说过这个。天哪，我们谈过这个。既聪明又有心理健康问题、焦虑问题、
overthinking issues, or dumb, not because you and not even think about it because you're dumb and you won't soften your words Meg. Okay, would you rather be smart and have to deal with like fucked thinking or would you rather be dumb and not have to think about it? But then also if you're dumb you get susceptible to capitalism and you get to, you work for nothing and you work hard for nothing.
过度思考问题的人，还是一个笨蛋，不用去想这些，因为你很笨，而且梅格，你甚至都不会斟酌词句。好吧，你是愿意聪明但不得不应付糟糕的思维方式，还是愿意变笨然后什么都不用去想？但话说回来，如果你很笨，你就会容易受到资本主义的盘剥，你会为了一无所有而工作，为了虚无拼命工作。
No, but that's not true. Yeah, but it's like lots of people. Yes, it is in senses. Yeah, in a sense. In lots of cases, people don't know what's out there. It's getting very good. Her eyes like manic. right now. She's like, they don't know what's out there.
不，那不是真的。对，但就像很多人……是的，在某种意义上是的。对，在某种意义上。在很多情况下，人们根本不知道外面有什么。这变得越来越好了。她的眼神现在看起来好狂热。她就像是在说，他们不知道外面有什么。
Some people just don't know what's out there. They haven't had that access and they, well they haven't, and they don't know what they can literally like do things. They can do what they want for so much easier. They can have such a good life but they haven't seen it. And like they're working so hard. I don't know. It really depends because like I had this like awful experience at the start of the year. It changes where I'm like, it's so fucked but it's like I know that being an intelligent person means that
有些人就是不知道外面有什么。他们没有接触过那些，他们没有，而且他们不知道自己其实可以做很多事。他们可以随心所欲地做事，其实要轻松得多。他们本可以过上很好的生活，但他们没见过。而且他们还在拼命工作。我不知道。这真的很难说，因为我在今年年初有过一次糟糕的经历。这改变了我的看法，我当时想，这太操蛋了，但我知道作为一个聪明人意味着
like it comes with so much, like the amount of time I'm in my own head. is like absolutely sickening. Sometimes I just wish that I could just like pull out my mind and like put it on a table. So I could just like be this like little figure that just doesn't think about stuff. Does not thinking about stuff necessarily mean that you're not intelligent?
这伴随着太多的代价，比如我困在自己脑海里的时间简直多到让人恶心。有时候我真希望自己能把大脑直接扯出来，然后把它放在桌子上。这样我就能变成一个小人儿，不用再去想那些乱七八糟的事了。不思考事情就一定意味着你不聪明吗？
Or is it just that you're better able to silence your thoughts? I don't know. Meditation, baby. Maybe if you just meditate heaps. That means you like, if I didn't, if I didn't even have to think about meditating and my thoughts just like went through. It's just like guys.
还是说，这只是说明你更有能力让自己的思绪安静下来？我不知道。冥想，宝贝儿。也许只要你疯狂地冥想。这意味着你——如果我甚至都不用去想冥想这件事，我的思绪就只是顺其自然地流过。就像是，天哪。
I feel like they just don't think. So guys are dumb. Men don't think. Yeah, that's actually, maybe emotionally, the intelligence. I don't know what, like, internal intelligence. Every man I've ever known has been a little bit stupid. Yeah, but they just, like, don't, they don't care. It's more, like, it's not like they don't care in a bad way.
我觉得他们就是不会去想。所以男人都是笨蛋。男人不会思考。对，实际上，也许在情感智力方面。我不知道，就像，内在智力。我认识的每个男人都有点蠢。对，但他们只是……就是不在乎。更像是……这倒不是说他们以一种不好的方式不在乎。
They just don't care. Like, they just, like, let things flow. I don't think that's true, though. I don't think that's true. I don't know, lots of, I don't know. Maybe a lot of, I feel like there are some that I've met who are very, but this is more about, like, anxiousness rather than intelligence, you know? Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, Madie, sorry, Meg, I didn't mean to disagree with you.
他们就是不在乎。就像，他们只是让事情顺其自然。不过我觉得这不是真的。我觉得这不是真的。我不知道，很多……我不知道。也许有很多，我觉得我遇到过一些非常……但这更多的是关于焦虑，而不是智力，你知道吗？好吧，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，麦迪，对不起，梅格，我不是故意要反驳你的。
No, I think. I think that being of a higher intelligence naturally makes you have a greater degree of existential awareness, which can make you more depressed. But I think that at the same time, I think it also allows you to have maybe richer experiences, form deeper connections. And I think the downside of that is that the things that you feel to perhaps are more heightened extreme in a good way that you might get to feel at an above average level to someone that is like uninclined to thinking in deeper ways.
不，我觉得。我觉得拥有更高的智力自然会让你具备更高程度的生存意识，这可能会让你更容易感到抑郁。但我认为与此同时，这也让你能够拥有或许更丰富的经历，建立更深厚的连接。我认为这样做的缺点是，你所感受到的事物可能更加强烈极端——以一种好的方式——与那些不倾向于深度思考的人相比，你可能会在一个高于平均水平的层面上感受到这些。
And you appreciate peace more. At the same time it comes with feeling the lows more acutely. So it just depends whether you want to kind of have consistency in a more plateaued, stable emotional life. But that's like shit because it's all relative, like, if we're happy, it means we've had to have sad times, you know? Absolutely. But, yeah, there was that other question.
而且你更懂得欣赏平静。与此同时，这也伴随着更加敏锐地感受到生活低谷的代价。所以这完全取决于你是想要一个更加平稳、稳定的情感生活。但这很糟糕，因为这一切都是相对的，如果我们感到快乐，就意味着我们必须经历过悲伤的时刻，你知道吗？绝对的。但是，对，还有另一个问题。
Do we, how can we know if we are happy? I might just, might have to move on to that in the next segment. I just have another point. Um, I just feel so bad. Like, why? I wish everyone, like, you know, you just, do you ever feel so bad about like, people like, why aren't they, you know, they could do so many things? I don't know, I just feel like.
我们……我们怎么知道自己是否快乐？我可能得在下一个环节讨论这个问题。我刚刚又想到一个观点。嗯，我只是觉得太难过了。就像，为什么？我希望每个人都……你知道吗，你有没有过这种感觉，就是为人们感到难过，比如，他们为什么不……你知道的，他们本可以做那么多事？我不知道，我只是觉得。
You've got built. Yeah, like, I just want everyone to be like a set. Maybe they are happy doing that. Yeah, I know. that's a good point that's a very good point but it's like but it's beautiful. Yeah that's a very good point actually but it's beautiful that you recognize their potential and you're like if I had that potential this is what I would do with it. Yeah but everyone's brains
你真是天生如此。对，就像，我只是希望每个人都……也许他们那样过得很开心。对，我知道，这是一个很好的观点，这是一个非常好的观点。但这就好比……但这很美妙。对，这是一个非常好的观点，你能识别出他们的潜力，并且你会想：“如果我有这种潜力，我就会用它来做这些事。”对，但每个人的大脑
wide different I suppose maybe they don't want that it's like my cousins yeah I love them to bits but they want very different things to me and I yeah it's a very good point. Yeah I feel like when I was younger I would often be like oh don't they see we are the most I like each individual is their own in most yeah absolutely well thank you all for listening we realized Maddie just realized that we have to go fucking clean up the kitchen. Can we ask the question? Well, we have one more question to leave with you.
结构都不一样，我想也许他们并不想要那样。就像我的表亲们——对，我爱死他们了，但他们想要的东西和我非常不一样，而我……对，这是一个很好的观点。对，我觉得我年轻的时候经常会想，哦，难道他们看不出来吗？我们是最……我喜欢每个人都是他们自己最……对，绝对的。好吧，谢谢大家收听，我们刚意识到——麦迪刚意识到我们得去把该死的厨房收拾干净了。我们能提个问题吗？好吧，我们还有一个问题留给大家。
Yeah, here's a good question for you. Should we banish the poet? Oh, damn, we didn't let. Who gets, who asked to clean the kitchen? So the first one is, how do you know whether you are happy? Oh, big one. I really wish we'd answered that. Maybe we can do a part two.
对，这里有个好问题留给你们。我们应该把诗人放逐吗？哦，该死，我们没让……谁负责收拾厨房？所以第一个问题是：你怎么知道自己是否快乐？哦，这是一个大问题。我真希望我们刚才回答了这个问题。也许我们可以做个第二期。
Okay, next time. Yeah. Yeah. And then Maddie's funny one is. I already said. it should we banish the poets? Yes. Have a think.
好吧，下次吧。对。对。然后麦迪那个有趣的问题是……我刚才说过了。我们应该把诗人放逐吗？是的。好好想想。
Oh my God. Remember when I was dating my, oh, I know Meg hates that I'm talking about men at the moment, but like, disgusting. Oh my God. Oh my God.
天哪。还记得我在跟我那个……哦，我知道梅格讨厌我现在谈论男人，但这简直太恶心了。天哪。天哪。
He used to write me poems and I literally want to fucking throw up. It was like, I saw this really funny meme the other day. It was like open to Snapchat expecting it to be a dick pick, but it was a poem, which is somehow so much worse. Yes.
他以前经常给我写诗，我简直想吐。就像，我前几天看到一个超级搞笑的表情包。上面写着：“打开Snapchat，以为会收到一张下体照，结果却是一首诗，这不知为何感觉更糟了。”对。
And I was like, I was like, yeah, that's so true. Anyhow, some beautiful questions coming out of this. I hope as you were listening, you kind of got to think about them as well. I think it's a really good, like, kind of mental exercise. Like, we were really in this moment, just
我当时就想，对，太真实了。无论如何，这次讨论中产生了一些非常美妙的问题。我希望你们在收听的时候，也能顺便思考一下这些问题。我觉得这是一个非常好的精神锻炼。就像，我们刚才真的完全沉浸在这个时刻里，
like discussing things, you know, all that worry about, like, whether the internet is, like, fucking with our cognition. But all will be okay. Yeah, if you just answer some of these Oxford questions. No need to overthink. If you ever think, it's okay. Maddie's the existentialist. What? I'm the mediator, and Meg is the passionate one. Like, that's... I'm an Aquarius. I'm an Aquarius. I'm a Pisces, well, water babies. No, isn't Aquarius? Get coaster.
讨论各种事情，你知道的，所有关于互联网是否在搞砸我们认知的担忧。不过一切都会好起来的。对，只要你能回答其中几个牛津大学的问题就行。没必要过度思考。如果你过度思考了，也没关系。麦迪是存在主义者。什么？我是调解员，梅格是充满热情的那一个。就像，那是……我是水瓶座。我是水瓶座。我是双鱼座，好吧，水象星座。不对，水瓶座不是……拿个杯垫来。
Not water. Aquarius, it's Aquarius. It's like Aquarium. It's an air sign. It's not an aquarium. It's an air sign. It's an air sign. It's an air sign.
不是水象。水瓶座，它是水瓶座。它是个风象星座。它不是水族馆。它是风象星座。它是风象星座。它是风象星座。
It's a water bearer, but we're an air sign. Air sign, yes. No, that is absolutely. Yes. You're telling me that cancer, cancer is a water sign, but Aquarius is not a water sign. Yes, I am. I'll show. Piceyce.
它是持水者，但我们是风象星座。风象星座，是的。不，这绝对是。对。你是说巨蟹座——巨蟹座是水象星座，但水瓶座不是水象星座。是的，我就是这个意思。我会证明的。双鱼座。
Anyhow. I forgot we were recording. Thank you so much for listening. I hope you enjoyed our beautiful guests. They mean so much to me, and I think they're amazing. So I really appreciate that they came on. Thank you for having us. No, it's okay.
不管怎样。我都忘了我们还在录音了。非常感谢大家的收听。希望你们喜欢我们的精彩嘉宾。他们对我意义重大，而且我觉得他们太棒了。所以我非常感谢他们能来。谢谢邀请我们。不，没关系。
Follow me on LinkedIn. Oh, no. I'll put it in the bio. I'm just kidding. Follow you on Strava? Strava, yes, that's a good one. LinkedIn Strava. And follow me on Instagram at Tony Psychology Podcast.
在领英上关注我。哦，不用。我会把它写在个人简介里的。我开玩笑的。在Strava上关注你？Strava，对，这个不错。领英、Strava。还可以在Instagram上关注我：Tony Psychology Podcast。
And also follow us wherever you get your podcast, Spotify, Apple, Google, Anchor. We're all over there. And if you're still listening, three cheers. Harrah Hurrah. Hurrah. Congratulations. Bye.
同时，无论你在哪里收听播客，也请关注我们：Spotify、Apple、Google、Anchor。我们到处都有。如果你还在收听，三呼万岁。好啦，好啦。好啦。恭喜。再见。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
欢迎收听《Look Back at it》播客。对对我来说，1979年是个大日子。1984年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
还有我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not have. mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of
欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披一副铠甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着
fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
你需要这么做。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
生下了一对双胞胎，但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你对这个特定的测试动过两次手脚，对吧？我动过一次测试的手脚。互联网侦探们出动了大批人马，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·兰基尼。我的天哪，三观尽毁。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。